this program is brought to you by Emory
University
so what about 30 years ago and I used to
always say whenever I talk about the
past I take everything I say is unbiased
and I take my inspiration from a famous
book called the unbiased history of the
Civil War a southern perspective three
things that I would like to emphasize
one is that aids really is a new disease
secondly that it's complicated and
thirdly that people are the most
important things so what I mean when
it's a new disease is not really when
when was the first infection transmitted
from a chimpanzee to a human which we
now know it was perhaps many decades ago
someplace in the middle of Central
Africa
but really when did it start to occur
with any frequency or any importance
anywhere and those early days in 1981 it
was a very uncommon occurrence to have
anybody sick with what we now know as
HIV and the United States was one of the
first first world or developed countries
to experience AIDS even in Africa where
HIV perhaps originated most countries
had no infections in no cases even in
the early 1980s and now we have
something which is the fourth leading
cause of death in the world and looks
like it's going to be here to stay for
the rest of our lives so it came from
nowhere became the leading cause of
death in Africa the fourth leading cause
of death in the world over a million
cases in the United States and more than
a half a million deaths in the United
States and it really is brand-new the
other thing is that it's so complicated
and we spend a lot of time as scientists
talking about the viral logic complexity
how complicated the virus is how
complicated the treatment is and indeed
it is really complicated to understand
when and how to use which drugs and how
to interact with them but the real
complexity is the social and cultural
complexity of the disease that makes it
difficult to understand why everybody
isn't tested why everybody isn't treated
why everybody doesn't have access to
health care why there remains so much
discrimination against homosexuality and
drug use and sexual transmission some of
it is easy to understand but in every
society it's very difficult to talk
about sex and in every community it's
difficult to talk about sex it's not so
difficult in many churches because they
simply don't do it but it's a very
complicated problem and it has to be
dealt with is complexity and that
complexity of course is what manages our
our daily life finally the last point is
that people make the difference I think
I've already spoken about many of you
HIV infected people themselves some of
whom are providers some of whom are
scientists many of whom were advocates
many of whom died during the first 15
years of the epidemic perhaps most of
the 500,000 gay men the first gay men
that got infected who died before heart
came along have made a huge difference
they've become role models for others
and how to live their lives openly with
a fatal infection that scares the hell
out of people that includes people like
Larry Kramer and Magic Johnson Ryan
White and and the supporters of people
who are HIV infected I mentioned Elton
John Michael Jackson Liz Taylor and
others who gave us something of
themselves to work with a controversial
topic the scientists and clinicians who
worked on AIDS have not only been
scientists and clinicians but have been
important advocates for their patients
and for the community and haven't been
afraid to take on topics which some of
their own provider colleagues laugh
about or are uncomfortable with oh
you're working with that disease but
instead they become advocates for the
world and they are really behind a lot
of the efforts in other countries the
preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University